just in time for world book day on
saturday let's check in with rocky who
is live at las vegas books to celebrate
early hi rocky
hey so i know i wanted to ask do they
have janelle monae's new book but no of
course this is a used bookstore but
however if it is on your list and after
people you know read it a couple times
and then want to bring it in they can do
that and you have a data system for that
right kelsey absolutely yeah there is an
option to put in a request with us so if
you're looking for something you want us
to keep an eye out for we'll put it in
as a request as soon as we get into
inventory we'll give you a call
the other thing we can do is look for
similar titles or authors
there's things that we have keyworded in
our system that we can just take a look
for so in this case i've looked up what
we might have that is afrofuturistic
uh and i've got a couple of options that
we would be able to look at if that's
something you're interested in which one
are just name them off really quick for
people oh uh we've got some octavia
butler classic we've got n.k jemisin up
and comer and we've got nettie okorafor
there you go so get these and then go
ahead and start the janelle monae right
get the classics and then the new
thank you kelsey and obviously you know
this data system is very unique to a
used bookstore usually you walk into a
used bookstore and there's not as much
organization but i do appreciate their
organization here at las vegas books and
also their unique thing so when people
come in you know whether they're from
out of town or local there's five most
asked or most frequently asked questions
right yes so the things we can ask the
most are what are your oldest book
what's your biggest book what's your
rarest book what's your most expensive
book and what's your biggest set
so we thought we'd highlight those real
quick so i'll start with our oldest book
right here
i'm scared to touch it
uh so this is the marshall achievements
of the scots nation it's uh it's
scottish military history this copy was
printed in 1711 so it's it's the oldest
thing we have in the store by about 100
years 17 11. wow okay most expensive
most expensive is our copy of the uh of
ronald reagan's biography here it's
leather bound it comes in this nice case
it's signed by president reagan here on
about the third page how much is it
going for uh this copy is thirty two
hundred and fifty dollars oh my goodness
okay and let's move on we have 30
seconds and your biggest collection
while we walk over here biggest uh
biggest collection is gonna be right
behind us over here this is the war of
the rebellion it's a hundred and twenty
eight volumes on the civil war wow
that's a heavy read yeah yeah uh
not not a weekend read no not at all but
i want before we before we um have to go
back i want to highlight local authors
again this is las vegas books so they
have to have a section of just local las
vegas authors and if there's somebody
watching who is an author or know
someone who is how do they get their
book in here just come on into the store
we we work directly with our local
authors so come on in we'll talk about
what we need to do to get you on the
shelf we'd be happy to any author any
artist
uh and really any uh experience level
awesome well this is the perfect place
to celebrate world book day on saturday
and just celebrate books and culture
beyond every day right i'll send it back
to you